hello everyone and welcome to round
fifteen of the 1970 palma de mallorca
inter-zonal
tournament it's Bobby Fischer against
Cuban international master
Eleazar humanists FG era now before we
talk about this match up a bit and you
know show you the game Fischer had an
excellent starts to the tournament then
he had four draws and the loss against
bent Larsen and then he got back on
track on the you know on his winning
streak beating f'ing Geller borislav Eve
Cove and in last game in round number 14
there are going to be managed so now he
faces a strong cuban international
master before this game they already
played three times and i believe the
result is they drew two games and one
game was won by by Fischer so this is a
game number four so far and it's it's a
very interesting game and we also do
have a nice photo of this matchup but
before that I prepared a nice photo
challenge and it's gonna be a bit
difficult for many of you as it's not a
chess player it's actually a Texas
Hold'em player but he has been promoting
a lot of chess
lately on Twitter and been playing a lot
of chess so I thought as I myself am a
big Texas Hold'em fan it would be a nice
idea so here it is the best of luck to
everyone who is the gentleman in the
photo here so there you have it
good luck to everyone and we do have a
photo of Bobby Fischer playing against
the LSR Turkey era but it's not a photo
of this encounter I found this on a
website that says that this is a photo
of a Fisher versus their Kara of the
1970 Palma de Mer control zone all
tournament but as you can see in this
photo Fischer has the black pieces
whereas in the game that I will show you
Fischer has the white pieces so this
could not be the game from 1970 form of
the American tour zone tournaments
rather I am pretty sure this is from
1965 havana tournament but okay
regardless we do have a nice photo of
them now let's check out the game so
Fischer has the white pieces and he
opens with E 4 we have E 5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 Bishop to b5 the rule opus
a6 more fees defense push up to a
four-night to F so
castles we have Bishop to e7 all
standard stuff here
rookie 1 d6 c3 castles and Fischer goes
for d4 immediately he captures on d4 see
captures on d4 and d5 now sort of
wasting the temple but as it seems it
should be okay for black II five Fischer
advances his pawn we have 93 409 Knight
to c3 sir Gera captures Knight captures
pawn captures and here you have to
decide what to play
as you can see Fischer has a very nice
pawn chain in the center c3 d4 a5 and he
also has a bishop pair but black also
has a better prepare so all in all it's
a pretty equal position white center
makes it a bit more pleasant to play as
he controls more space and black will
eventually try to undermine the center
via C five or maybe even f6 if possible
so first developing pieces Bishop to f5
and it's a very nice square for the
bishop also later Bishop to g6 will be
possible and it prevents Fischer from
from developing this rook to a nice semi
open B file and while here you could
consider a lot of moves like if you
really want to play rook to be one you
could consider a bishop to see to simply
counter the bishop on f5 as it is a very
nice piece on f5 you could consider
something like h3 Queen to be to simply
developing Bishop to e3 but Fischer goes
for the immediate Bishop captures on c6
let's see how this plays out for him
bee captors on c6 and now Queen to a4
simply going for the for the doubled c6
pawn
we have c5 advancing and attacking
Fischer's pawn Center and here first
replace D captures on c5 a very nice
idea
ruining his pawn center but he does have
an idea why he did it with Bushnell
captures on c5 and now Bishop to a3
Queen to e7 Bishop captures on c5 Queen
captures on c5 and now Knights to d4
attacking this Bishop on f5 here at sir
Cara defends it
we have Bishop to g6 and now comes Queen
to c6 Fischer offers a try a trade of
Queens rather he forces the trade of
Queens in a retreat of the Queen will be
met with white simply developing ended
then
grabbing the c-7 point so Queen captures
on c6 Knight captures on c6 and now rook
F to e8 here Fischer simply moves the
knight back Knight back to before
attacking the the d5 pawn but also
pressuring the a sex bones so what do
you do here it's a very nice idea of
course you cannot defend the pawn via
via this route because this rope has to
keep an eye on the a sex pawn and if you
try something like rook a 38 then you
get rook 831 and now you see that
there's really no good way to defend it
so here
LSR finds a very nice idea he plays c6
defending the d5 pawn with the c6 pawn
and offering the c6 pawn and as it is
the best move to play in this position
Fischer captures it we have Knight
captures on c6 and only now rook a to
see it attack in Fishers night so if the
knight moves the c3 pawn will be lost
but always well as Fischer goes nice to
before now with an attack against d6
pawn rook captures on c3 and now first
Knight captures on d5 if Knight captures
an a6 then black can immediately start
pushing his past D pawn
so instead after rook c3 first batter is
to capture the D pawn and then deal with
the a 6-point later we have rook to a3
we have now f4 defending d5 pawn and now
comes h5 Fischer would of course enjoy
playing g4 + f5 trapping blacks Bishop
so black prevents any King sided
expansion we have nice to e3 now also
preparing to push f5 so Bishop to d3
rook a to d1 pressuring the bishop so
now rook captures on a2 is not possible
and rook to b8
rook the d2 adding further protection to
DA to pawn rook to be one attacking
Fischer's II one rook and now comes King
to f2 rook captures only one King
captures anyone and now comes a bishop
to be one with a double attack against
the DA to pawn so although Fischer is up
upon Eleazar really made a nice
calculation with that c6 move defending
d5 that he will have that his pieces
will enjoy enough activity at
you know counterfeiters extra phone so
Fisher knows that there's no way to
actually protect the a two point you do
have to make the best of it
so he goes work the d8 check King to h7
and now comes King to f2 and what do you
do here do you capture with the rook or
with the bishop well both is fine in the
game
Eleazar captures with the bishop as it
immediately defends the f7 pawn so we
have f5 here Fischer is preparing to
push a to at some point push a six and
hopefully create a nice pass pawn we
have looked to a5 attacking Fisher's c5
pawn and here comes rook to e8 defending
it rooftop b5 and now Eleazar makes room
for his own passed pawn to start pushing
it and here a fresh replace King to f3
it's very interesting
there's if you try and push immediately
to create a passport then this is a
forced draw drawn line as after pawn
captures captures rook e5 with a double
attack against d6 pawn you push r e7 now
comes Bishop to f7 you force the rook
away from the defense of the e7 pawn
rook e8
rook captures rook captures and now it's
two pawns each and the King side a night
against the bishop and two rooks
so completely equal endgame so a troop
to b5 Fischer tries to improve King to F
3 and a 5 Eliezer starts pushing his own
passport King to f4 we have a 4 simply
continuing to pull the pond rope to a8
again we see the same theme over and
over you have to put a rope behind the
passed pawn so we have worked before
defending the pawn this comes with check
King to f3 King to g5 is also an idea
perhaps you know you just want to
advance the King further but then rook
to e4 comes and then you're a 5 point is
attacked and also your knight and e3 is
attacked so it will be actually black
wool who'll profit for the from this so
rook to before we have King to f3 now
comes Bishop to b3 protecting the a 4
point so now the rook can move Fischer
goes h3 and now comes Rock to b5
attacking Fischer's a 5 pawn and as you
can see the bishop here is guarding c4
the point here is guarding g4 so there
is no
way there is no way for a fisher to
defend d5 pawn with the night the only
way to defended a scheme to e4 or King
to f4 so Fisher defends the King to f4
and now look to be four check once again
and as we've seen team g5 is impossible
so Fisher goes back into f3 and here
rook to b5 attacking e5 pawn and as
black black is somewhat better in this
position but he is perfectly satisfied
with a draw he does not want to push
instead of rook b5 he could perhaps play
g6 you know keep his options open and
you know try to go for something more
than half a point here but international
Cuban international master LSR him and
Sergei is satisfied with a draw against
Bobby Fischer with the black pieces so
instead he doesn't put for anything Ruby
5 and it was in this position that they
agreed to a draw so a very nice game
from both of them and it's very
interesting it's not all that clear
worded I mean both of them that's why I
use this quote above the board my
opponents make good moves too sometimes
I don't think I take these things into
consideration as a display this game was
played very nicely by black and there
was no way to put for anything more here
with the white pieces perhaps you know
after this Bishop to a5 move was played
maybe Bishop captures on c6 was a to
forcing and it allowed the black to go
into a simplified position perhaps too
quickly maybe continuing the game with
with the moves we suggested Bishop c2 or
maybe a ch3 Queen e2 would have given
white you know more chances to
complicate but you know Fischer or often
prefer this Bishop captures on c6 move
in the rule opus so you know if his
opponent's defended really well which
was the case here then the game was
drawn so yeah after this rook to b5 move
the game was drawn and this is how
around fifteen of the nineteen seventy
palm of America inter-zonal tournament
went for Bobby Fischer so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and that
you're enjoying the coverage of the
Bobby Fischer series so far as usual you
can check two of my previous videos your
thing called for watching and I do have
a question for the end of this video for
you I don't know if any of you are still
using myspace but I've been trying to
listen to one song in my space it's a
song my friend uploaded and whenever I
hit the play button the song just
doesn't play it I mean there's no good
reason I can think of for this but it
just doesn't so if you have any idea
about this you know feel free to share
it in the comments and also one you know
sort of a notification or you know an
announcement I'm considering
participating in an open tournament so
if you have any interesting open
tournaments in mind you know also do
share in the comments you know so I have
more of them to consider from if that's
something you would enjoy of course so
yeah that's it thank you and I will see
you soon